hey everyone this is Jeremy she flying
with Khan Academy super excited to be
joining you this evening for our session
on getting started with remote learning
and just to sort of set the tone for the
evening we know that there's some
challenging times out there and we're
all struggling to figure out as parents
and educators what can we do to serve
our students and our children in the
best way possible and so with that in
mind if you want to give you a sense of
who's gonna be sharing their stories
with you tonight and then what you can
do next
so joined on the line is Megan ppattani
who is Khan Academy's lead educator
training teachers all around the country
as you can see she was an amazing high
school biology teacher high school track
and field coach you also have myself
former kindergarten teacher mostly known
for teacher tides and making smoothies
for his kids and that being said I want
to give you a chance to introduce
yourselves so I want to start with a
couple of quick questions these are
pretty important because I'm going to
use these that can form the live
demonstration we do in the next few
minutes so go ahead and answer this
question what grade level do you teach
I'll board from elementary to high or
even beyond be curious to find out again
we'll use that to really personalize the
kind of experiences you see on the
screen in a few minutes okay we're gonna
close this poll in a few minutes
three two one I'll share those results
and it looks like we've got a big chunk
of high school teachers here as well as
some elementary and middle so that's
fantastic thanks for joining I ask you
one other question as well which is
regardless of school level what subject
you teach everything from math to ela
let's know more
participating go ahead and close this
poll share the results sure enough it
looks like we've got a plurality of math
teachers but also some folks from across
the disciplines so thanks again for
joining okay so that being said I want
to answer a couple of sort of ground
rules for this webinar for those who are
curious you will absolutely get a
recording of this afterwards that you
can share with anyone you like fellow
educators administrators even parents
and then absolutely please use the
questions feature at any point Megan's
gonna respond to your questions right
now as you type them in and then we're
gonna take some questions live as well
so please let us know what's on your
mind and we'll respond in real-time okay
that ping said the three big questions
that we're gonna address this evening
are as follows number one why do you
even want to use Khan Academy for remote
learning in the first place we'll dive a
little bit into the underpinnings of our
site number two how can you use Khan
Academy to make a rote learning as
effective as possible we know you've got
this big challenge in front of you we
want to give you all the tools and
resources to be as successful as you can
and I'm third and finally what else is
on your mind how can we help as you sort
of face this next step and preparing
your students for success so that being
said I want to start with this beginning
question of why use Khan Academy for
remote learning and the reason I've
chosen these images on the screen which
take you back to the very early days of
Khan Academy as Sal Khan himself was
building it out of decade ago is that
even though we often associate Khan
Academy with the classroom today at it's
very beginning everything on Khan
Academy was remote Sal was sitting in
his closet as you can see creating the
video is creating the content and became
the first lessons on Khan Academy and
the result is because that's always been
part of our DNA
even as we move into the classroom you
can be sure of two things number one
condom Academy is for learners who are
learning anytime you don't have to be
working at the same time as students
they can respond to the specific skills
you want them to practice they get
instant feedback as soon as they do and
you always keep tabs and how your
students are doing and then number two
no matter where you are no matter where
your learners are
Khan Academy can bring you together
computers don't a students don't even
need a computer they can now access Khan
Academy on smartphones using our app or
the mobile website and in addition our
content is available in over 40
languages and as a nonprofit it's all
free for you all free for your students
so that's why Khan Academy is sort of
uniquely built for this moment because
this is the moment that we came from ok
so now the most important question how
can you use Khan Academy to derive great
remote learning for your students so to
make this really come alive I'm going to
use some of those recommendations that
you just gave I'm going to put them to
use live on the screen for your benefit
so I'm going to split screen mode here
and what you see on the right hand side
is actually a bit alive Khan Academy
site the same way you see it if you log
in at Khan Academy that'll work
so the question the students often the
teachers often ask is how do I even get
started how do I get my students
enrolled so if you want to do that all
you have to do is come over here and a
lot of folks that hey I'm a high school
math teacher so maybe you're teaching
algebra and so you have your classroom
and if you want to add new students you
have three different options that are
categorized into fastest oldest and
youngest and explain what that means I'm
going to come over here to the admin
section and then down to students and
under students you're gonna see this
link to add new students and when you do
that you get the exact same option that
you see there on the slide do you wanna
use Google classroom you want students
to join with a class link or do you want
to actually enroll your students
yourself so the reason I say Google
classroom is the fastest is that if you
already have a Google classroom account
all you have to do is connect that and
then import your students right away and
you're all set and they're there in Khan
Academy so that is definitely the
fastest way to get started but if you
don't have Google classroom and you do
have older students maybe middle school
or high school you can absolutely have
them join themselves really quickly all
you have to do is click that button
students join them to class link and you
get a custom code that you can put on
your whiteboard on a screen on an email
where they can just join now you've
logged into your classroom right away
and if you actually download the handout
that I've included here in the
GoToWebinar panel you can actually get a
special handout or slide to
dear students with information when it
has at the very end is your unique class
code which identifies your class from
every other one on Khan Academy and then
finally for your very youngest students
for the elementary teachers out there
you can actually create your students
accounts on your own very quickly all
you have to do is type in their names
and then voila Khan Academy does two
things for you number one is it
generates unique username and number two
is it generates unique password and then
if you create those accounts you can
actually download all that information
and then print it off for your students
give handouts for your students have
them take it home and they're ready to
go so those are the three options get
started from fastest all the way to
oldest and youngest students so that
things said and the former teacher
myself I can't resist the opportunity to
give you a little pop quiz so quick
question for everyone out there where
can you find your class code is it
located under course mastery under
assignments or under settings which of
those three areas on your classroom
dashboard are gonna take you to your
class code thank you for everyone for
weighing in very quickly here this is
awesome we've got almost 400 folks
around the country sharing their
feedback I will go ahead and close this
poll and share the results and so you're
absolutely right settings is where you
want to go and just to recap that if you
come back here to your classroom page
you're skipping past course mastery past
assignments and you come to the admin
section and you can find your class code
in your students area right over here or
in your settings field right over here
that's always where you're going to find
your class code okay so next section
once your students are enrolled how do
you get them prepared what we're gonna
recommend is if you have the ability to
work with your students now before
school close your events you're going to
have the best chance to really get
students comfortable with a platform and
familiar with the routines associated
with it so we highly recommend that you
start by assigning this is a simple
skill to practice so they understand the
basic mechanics of Khan Academy and they
feel confident and in charge when they
use it at home
that being said you really recommend
that you add yourself to your own class
so you can try it too because as
important as your students practice
we've seen time and again the most
successful educators with Khan Academy
are the ones who feel confident about
them themselves and who include
themselves in the experience so taking
this class code for instance if you want
to add yourself to your class just let's
see what students are receiving the
emails that are generated what an
assignment looks like all you have to do
is come here to your name in the top
right hand corner go to your learner
home not your teacher dashboard and then
on this learner page which is all about
you as a student not as a teacher you're
gonna come down to this very bottom
section called teachers all you have to
do is plug in your class code and you
can join your very own class
now you'll see everything the same way
that students do so you can know before
you make an assignment everything is the
way that you want it and that's how you
join your class now the other thing is a
little bit less technical and that is
not only should students be familiar
with Khan Academy but they should feel
ready for success in general so I think
there are a couple things you can do
today to really make sure they're set up
for success tomorrow
number one do students have their Longet
login information handy if you download
the handout that I've attached here I
have a simple worksheet that you can
print off and hand out to your students
where they can write down that
information including the login address
so they have that or can even share that
with their parents that's the first step
of course for your older students who
may have their own smartphones or
devices let them know that they can
access kind of Academy not just through
a computer but also through the Khan
Academy app on iOS or Android and if you
have younger students maybe they don't
even have a computer at home and you're
worried about equity issues let them
know that they can also access Khan
Academy on their parents smart device
even if they go to the mobile website or
if they want to download the app so
another option to make sure all of your
students are served all of your students
have access and then finally Megan
really reiterated this to me before this
conversation tonight which is you want
to have a lifeline to your students go
to Meghan was teaching in Connecticut
during the time of Hurricane sandy she
made sure that she had a clue
your line of communication to her kids
using an LMS or an app like classdojo or
remind or even just email and to make
sure that you have that stuff in advance
students know where to receive
information from you and then also know
that Khan Academy will assist you by
sending notifications to your students
so if they have the app or if they have
access to email they'll be notified that
they have an assignment or course
mastery goal and that'll keep them
moving towards the right goal okay that
being said I want to ask a little pop
quiz just to see if everyone sort of
caught that important pro tip about
adding yourself to your class if you
want to add yourself to your own class
on Khan Academy do you do that by going
to your student roster by going to your
learner dashboard or by going to the
students tab of your home page just to
check for understanding here old teacher
habits die hard
groaning across the country so quickly
I'll go ahead and close the poll share
the results
voila you nailed it again you leave the
sort of cozy confines of your teacher
dashboard and come over to learner home
and I'm there under the teacher section
you can add your class code and join
your own class it's exactly what your
students see okay nicely done so just
two final sections and we're gonna open
it up for some live Q&A so once you have
your students enrolled once you have
them set up for success how do you get
the communication going how do you get
assignments flowing well a set up
assignments which is sort of a basic
functionality of Khan Academy all you
have to do is come back to your teacher
dashboard come into your class so again
so we're putting ourselves in the shoes
of high school math teachers everywhere
so maybe you're teaching algebra maybe
you're teaching pre calc and you come
over here to the assignments tab
specifically you click a sign and then
you have your entire curriculum laid out
for you so maybe you chose a couple of
different courses pre-algebra algebra
one maybe even a little bit of early
math in this case let's go to algebra
one and say hey right now we're in the
quadratics section of the year but let's
dig in there and say I specifically want
my students to watch a polynomials video
and do an exercise on polynomials sort
of an introductory level and if you want
to check those out yourself all you have
to do is click on them by clicking on
the exercise you can instantly see the
total database of questions that
students will be faced with and once
you've checked that out and it feels
good to you you can close that tab and
click the assign button the nice thing
about assignments just like an
assignment in class you choose the due
date the due time and you choose the
specific students you can have all
students work on the same thing or if
you're ready to do a little
differentiation focus on the students
who really need a little bit of remedial
work and folks who are ready to move
ahead you can choose that as well and
then lastly as you see here on the
screen there is this pro tab which is if
you really want to make sure that
everyone has a different experience you
can do that but there is an advantage to
giving the same questions to all
students which you're about to see on
the next slide either way you make your
choice and you click the assign button
now that assignment goes out to the
students they're notified and they're
off to the races
so that's getting an assignment started
but how do you review progress how do
you sort of close that feedback loop
with how the students are doing so if
you come over to the scores tab right
beneath the sign you can now see the
results that are coming in from all
these assignments on a student level
which is nice to know that your students
are actually getting your assignments
completing them understand how they're
performing but you can actually dig into
the assignment itself and figure out how
they did question my question across
your student body and the reason I
shared that protip of having a shared
set of questions is that let's say
you're in a situation we're able to do a
video conference with your students for
30 minutes a day and you can share your
screen using something like zoom or
Google Hangouts well what you can do is
you can actually go through those
questions and point out aha
there's clearly a misunderstanding here
we're seeing a pattern where a lot of
students are missing the same thing let
me actually correct that
misunderstanding at the root and you can
actually draw right on the screen if you
want to and it even gives students hints
to give them a sense of how they can
sort of scaffold all the way up to the
right answer and that way even if you're
not directly connected with students you
could have that same level of feedback
that same level of guidance that
characterizes the best teachers anywhere
so that's how you get assignments going
now one pop quiz for you here is do you
have to assign the same exercise to all
students so think about this question
for a second is it mandatory to give the
same assignment to every single student
or can you differentiate can you spread
it around I know this is an easy one we
just talked about it just want to
confirm this because it's very important
which is that Khan Academy is really
focused on letting teachers
differentiate and serve every learner
where they are and so even though you
may be tempted to just sort of assign
one assignment to every single student
if you know that a student needs
something different feel free to use the
assignments tool to pick and choose the
students the same way you would in your
own classroom okay so that is the
assignment piece and then finally this
idea of mastery goals of course it
brings up the question is what exactly
is a mastery goal let me explain a
mastery goal this way
we've just talked about assignments
which can often be very short-term do
this problem set tomorrow watch this
video by tonight and that's great that
gets you through the day especially when
you're starting with your remote
learning cadence but if you know that
you're gonna be out of school for two
weeks three weeks or more and you want
to set a longer-term objective a mastery
goal is about setting their horizon
about where you want students ahead even
if we're not gonna be able to be with
them for a month or more at a time so
that's the first thing mastery goal does
the second thing is that lets you set a
really high bar as you just saw with
assignments much of the focus is on get
it done and get a score similar to
worksheets but if you want to say hey
it's not just about getting through the
assignment it's about mastering the core
underlying skill that's where mastery
goals come in because they let you say
hey I don't want you moving forward you
just sort of going through the motions
and these next two or three weeks I want
you to always push yourself to really
understand and master this new skill
that's what a mastery goal can help with
and so in terms of why you want to use
them for remote learning number one we
all know that one of the biggest sort of
issues are the remote learning is that
students can feel disempowered Here I am
behind the screen I'm not able to
connect with my teacher as directly
maybe I'm just going through the motions
whereas a mastery goal let's at eat a
student work as fast or as slowly as
they need to to ultimately master those
key skills they're the driver of their
destiny they had that level of
empowerment I mean number two when
students do come back to school you
don't want to have wide gaps because
students were going really quickly
through your online assignments instead
you want to make sure you fill in those
foundational gaps and mastered goals
really Drive students toward that level
of understanding before they move on so
how do you assign mastery goals in your
classroom well to come back to our
teacher dashboard here we're gonna go
from assignments to the course mastery
tab we're gonna click placement what you
can do here is you can create a goal for
as few or as many students as you want
and these goals are typically set at the
course level so you might say you know
by the end of this year I want every one
of my students to have mastered all the
key skills of Algebra one I can assign
that's all of them or part of them
and I can attend appropriate to date and
that's the way that you get started
but then the magic of Khan Academy's
course mastery goals come through
actually experiencing what students see
so again if you ever want to see what it
looks like on the student side you come
back to your name menu at the very top
right hand corner you go to live in her
home and then you come over here to
course mastery you can see exactly what
the goal looks like on the student side
and you can see what it looks like as
they click in and go through mastering
their skills and again when you talk
about empowerment so much of it it's
about understanding what you've
accomplished and this really gives
students a clear sense for what have I
mastered what do I still have left to
work on and then finally as you want to
check that progress yourself as a
teacher you come back to your teacher
dashboard which you can always do just
by clicking the Khan Academy logo at the
very top of the screen you come in to
your desired class and then instead of
clicking the placement tab you click the
progress tab here you can really dig in
the course mastery and an entire course
level as well as at a unit level so for
example if you assigned a course mastery
goal but you want to understand how
students are doing with variables you
can find out that aha we have some
students who have really mastered them
which is awesome but we have some
students like Tori and Casey maybe need
a little bit extra practice and you can
actually click the assign button and
assign that practice just to the right
student to give them a helping hand even
from afar to make sure they have
everything they need to be successful
and are constantly pushing towards that
high bar of mastery so that's how you
check progress that's how you keep your
students moving forward so that being
said I want to finish up with one final
pop quiz so as many folks out there will
know a Tim Vandenberg was one of our
Khan Academy at-bat ambassadors and
there's a sixth grade math teacher in
Hesperia California he did a really
awesome webinar for us last week where
he talked about the progress that his
students made using course mastery
exclusively not even using assignments
and so for anyone who was on that
session I'm curious if you recall the
incredible progress his students made in
terms of the California math assessment
the high stakes test and all the
students had to take at the end of fifth
grade
look like these results will close the
poll we'll share them with the audience
and sure enough you're absolutely right
Tim had this astounding leap if you
remember that quote that graph which is
kind of burned into my retinas which is
his students started sixth grade sixty
points below grade level and they ended
up 34 points above way more progress
than the state made or the district made
or the county made on average and he
attributed it all to the fact that
focusing on mastery and filling those
gaps kept his students really making
sure they had all the foundations they
needed to be successful so even in this
difficult time I recommend checking it
out just see what's possible as you try
remote learning so that said let me
close out with two final next steps and
then we're gonna open up some live
questions so first of all if you haven't
already go to the handout section and
get my total cheat sheet to this entire
process enrolling your students getting
them ready for success making your first
assignment setting your first course
master goals you can feel free to
download that share that with educators
down the hall share that with your
administrators and then number two if
you have any questions whatsoever please
feel free to put them into the questions
box and Meghan and I will answer those
now so let's go ahead and start with
some good questions that have been
coming in and thank you everyone who's
been asking these so let's start with
this important question from Karen
Leonard I'm gonna bring this up to Megan
because Megan is our expert teacher
trainer and she'll be able to respond
directly to this question Karen Karen
wants to know are there standards
connected to each activity Megan and if
so are the national or state standards
it's a great question so for all of our
math content and for our ela content
which we do have a small section of ela
content in beta for those that might be
looking for that it's all Common Core
aligned and from the teacher perspective
if you go to make an assignment the same
way Jeremy is showing you on your screen
all of the Common Core Standards will
appear there for you the alternative is
that if you're looking for content maybe
to align to your existing curriculum is
that in our sir
feature you can search by topic but you
can also search by standard some other
things that might be helpful if you're a
science teacher we do have some NGSS
aligned content and if you're an AP
teacher all of our AP courses are
aligned to the AP standards and you can
search by those as well if you're a high
school teacher interested in SAT
preparation we do have official SAT
practice and inside our SAT practice our
content can be identified by state
specific standards so only in the SAT
part can you identify by state specific
standards otherwise it is national
standards mostly Common Core well a
great question Karen thanks for the
great answer Megan okay so next question
here so just see here melissa Lopez
wants to know would you recommend Megan
that teachers share an account to work
with students so let's say that you have
you know maybe students in common with
another teacher so you have a single
account a separate account what's the
best way to set that up
if students that are across multiple
teachers I believe is what the question
is getting at is that your students can
have as many teachers as they'd like and
if they're making if you're using
progress tracking opposed to our
individual assignments we're using
progress starting any teacher who has
that student on their roster can see
their progress so if for example you are
you know third grade teacher and you're
using it for math but you might also
have support instructors in your
classroom or additional you know Parris
who are in your classroom they can have
an account as well they can track
student progress for students and so
that way teachers even though you can't
share an account you're able to have
access to students progress cool okay
this is a really important question from
Camden King this goes way beyond
technology any tips Megan how to
actually get the kiddos to do the work
maybe using incentives beyond grades yes
what a great question for sure and so
there's a couple of things depending on
the you know age group demographics of
your students we find different success
of this so Khan Academy also Awards
students energy points while they're
completing assignments or
doing work and those energy points allow
them to upgrade avatars and earn badges
and some sort of some of those internal
kind of gamification people pieces we
find to be really motivating for
students on top of that we find that
teachers like to [ __ ] overall progress
and provide incentives around that some
of them can be as simple as we have
printable certificates on the site that
show you oh you mastered five skills or
you've really gone ahead or some
teachers create their own you completed
all of first grade that's amazing and
just recognize on that whereas other
teachers you know start to say if you
make X amount of progress will award the
class with you know some sort of prizes
which might be a little bit challenging
as we think about remote learning but I
know that some teachers will you know
send again digital recognition either in
a certificate or you know some teachers
really go all the way to Amazon
giftcards I'm not encouraging that it's
just something we've seen there in real
classrooms but ways to recognize student
progress cool I've seen a couple
questions here about K through 2 or even
preschool I do want to call out Khan
Academy for kids which is our sister
program it's all focused on ages two to
six and helping to them really sort of
build the foundations for numbers sense
and for reading and language arts and so
if you're interested in that that's a
free app that you can download on iOS or
Android so definitely check out the Kahn
kid kids app as you can see right here
sort of going along with that question
megan tina Luffman asks does Khan
Academy have any reading lessons or is
this really just for math it's not just
for math which I do what I think that's
a common misconception is that we did
start with math but Khan Academy offers
math science and engineering computer
science arts humanities economics we're
partnered with College Board as I
mentioned and we have free official SAT
practice along with a fair amount of AP
content including things of AP computer
science principles AP US history ap
biology is just getting a revamp so
there's plenty of content beyond math
our ela content is just in its early
development and so if you are and
English Language Arts teacher and you're
looking for some content we do have some
and we would love to get your feedback
on that as well as we think about
developing that further and if you have
early learners as Jeremy mentioned we do
have the Khan Academy kids app which is
focused on both early literacy and early
numeracy along with social-emotional
learning so if you have kiddos that are
in that 2 to 7 age range we've just
published all first-grade content last
week very exciting for us so if you're
looking for that type of content I
highly encourage you to look at the Khan
Academy kids app which has a much more
robust language and reading component
awesome
our moreno has a really interesting
question which is obviously for a lot of
students even if they don't have
internet access themselves they might
have it through a parent smartphone or
through the library but if there's just
no internet access available
what would we recommend in that case
Meghan yeah it's a really tricky one and
and we do deal with this with some of
the you know students we do work with
school districts all over the US which
obviously you know every school every
district has their own accessibility
concerns and so one thing I will say is
that everything as Jeremy so kindly
pointed out everything that's available
to students on the website is available
to them through the app and so even if
they only have access to a smartphone
they can access the full content library
all of their assignments from you all of
that is still available and so we find
that a lot of students might at least
have access to a smartphone for even a
small part of their week and so that is
one thing we do see leveraged quite a
bit if they have no access at all there
is an option that if you look at our
Help Center how do we help students who
have no internet access we do have a
partnership with organization called
learning equality and they have an
option where a student can download
content and access it offline however
they would still need a device in order
to do that to get the content we don't
offer printouts of all our exercises but
it's Jeremy showing you on the screen if
you look at our Help Center and you find
there again Colibri which is part of
learning equality they
you offer an ability to download Khan
Academy and other content they're not
exclusively for us and so that students
can access that offline and we do see
that use quite a bit mostly outside the
US but inside the US and a few locations
as well fantastic let's just close with
one final question which is there's no
certificates how would a teacher go
about getting access to those Megan as
well as any other teacher resources they
were developing great great question so
once you log into Khan Academy in yellow
dropped into your teacher dashboard
there's a place for you and Jeremy I
believe is going to navigate to us right
there called resources that tab that
Jeremy's hovering over and there you can
see getting started with teacher
training we have some teacher training
options there including a welcome guide
in some videos that show how teachers
have been using Khan Academy there's
also some additional resources when you
go into that and you'll find resources
for parents there's some out of school
program suggestions I know I used to
work with Boys and Girls Club of America
quite a bit and they would use their
after-school programs all of those types
of things like certificates and
printables you can find them there if
you're having trouble finding them
always feel free to go to our Help
Center and even if you do something as
simple as put certificates into the
search bar of our Help Center yeah just
like that
you'll be able to see them and they do
come in multiple languages and those are
printable for your students so great
okay so let's end up there Meghan thank
you so much for sharing your expertise
with our audience and thank you to our
audience for taking the time out of your
afternoon or evening to be with us I
know there's so much going on right now
we appreciate you investing in the
session that being said do us one final
favor please take the poll that pops up
at the very end of this webinar and let
us know hey how can we make future
iterations of the session even better
and then B what kinds of sessions would
you like to see going next obviously
this is a relatively high level session
about getting started if you want us to
dive deep into math or ela or motivation
or keeping students engaged in a remote
learning environment please just let us
know I'll be sure to build it out for
our next session so on behalf of Meghan
myself thank you so much for making time
to join us today we wish you tremendous
success
as you get your students set up for
remote learning and if there's anything
at all we can do to be of service please
just let us know thank you again so much
thank you very much
you